Estados Unidos sufrió en este país su única
derrota militar.
Ocurrió en la década de los 60 y 70 en la
que fue una guerra feroz, larga y muy impopular….
Tanto que terminó con la carrera política
del Presidente demócrata Lyndon B. Johnson
y supuso, de facto, el fin del modelo estadounidense
de política exterior vigente desde la II
Guerra Mundial.
El horror vivido fue de tal dimensión que
provocó la rebelión de toda una generación
contra el imperio de la fuerza y consiguió,
por ejemplo, que las guerras dejasen de ser
populares en Hollywood.
Desde entonces, la memoria colectiva se construyó
a través de películas-denuncia como como
Platoon, la chaqueta metálica o Apocalypsis
Now.
Sí, lo has adivinado, hablamos de Vietnam,
un país que marcó un antes y un después
en la historia de EEUU.
En este vídeo te contamos que ha ocurrido
desde entonces.
Os lo contamos en un vídeo anterior: Vietnam
es el país del mundo donde más apoyo popular
tiene el capitalismo.
En concreto, según datos del Pew Research
Center, el 93% de la población considera
que el libre mercado es el mejor modelo posible,
un porcentaje muy superior al que registra
cualquier potencia occidental.
Sí, amigos, aunque resulte chocante, hoy
el capitalismo y el libre mercado es más
popular en Vietnam que en los mismísimos
Estados Unidos.
Veamos por qué.
EL DESPEGUE DE VIETNAM
En solo unas pocas décadas, Vietnam ha experimentado
una trasformación enorme: ha pasado de ser
una sociedad agrícola a convertirse en una
pujante nación industrial.
Desde el año 2000 este país ha vivido un
auténtico boom económico, y su crecimiento
anual medio ha sido de casi el 7%, al tiempo
que la capacidad de consumo de sus habitantes
se ha multiplicado por 6 en poco más de 15
años.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
Cada vez son más las multinacionales que
anuncian inversiones millonarias en este país.
Por ejemplo, agarraros a la silla, tan solo
Samsung ha anunciado inversiones en este país
por valor de 20.000M$ ¡Casi nada!
Hoy, ciudades como Hanói o Ho Chi Min – la
antigua Saigón –son a Vietnam lo que Pekín
y Shanghai son a China.
Es decir, se están convirtiendo en pujantes
metrópolis donde los proyectos urbanísticos
y empresariales se cuentan por cientos.
Y ojo, porque no hablamos de cualquier cosa.
Según PWC, también conocidos como…
“House Water Watch Cooper” Ho Chi Minh
se convertirá en una de las principales ciudades
del mundo en apenas una o dos décadas y será
una de las dos ciudades que más crecerán
de aquí a 2025.
Así que, si aún no tenéis claro donde está
esta ciudad o queréis hacer negocios, ya
la podéis buscar en el mapa.
Pero, seguro que os preguntáis, ¿no es acaso
Vietnam un país comunista?
¿Es esta una especie de triunfo del comunismo?
Pues no del todo.
EL COMUNISMO EN VIETNAM
Sí, es verdad, oficialmente el país continúa
siendo una dictadura comunista, pero podemos
decir que su modelo de apertura a la inversión
y al comercio exterior es muy similar al que
experimentó China tras las reformas de Deng
Xiaoping, de las que, por cierto, Fonseca
ya nos habló en este vídeo.
Pero, regresemos a Vietnam: aunque el país
se haya abierto al comercio y a la inversión
exterior, es cierto que aún muchas empresas
siguen siendo propiedad del gobierno.
Concretamente casi la mitad de las 500 mayores
empresas del país.
Pero por otro lado, también es verdad que
cada vez son más numerosos los planes para
privatizar muchas de estas empresas.
Y, ojo, el régimen vietnamita lo hace de
una forma muy capitalista.
En vez de buscar a multinacionales para venderles
las empresas públicas, como es muy común,
por ejemplo, en Latinoamérica, en Vietnam
el gobierno por lo general las saca a cotizar
en su particular Wall Street: la bolsa de
Ho Chi Minh.
De esta forma, cualquier persona puede apostar
e invertir en estas compañías y, desde luego,
el modelo es más transparente, consigue mejorar
la recaudación del estado y no destruye la
competencia.
También hay otras diferencias con China:
por ejemplo, aunque las exportaciones y las
inversiones industriales van viento en popa,
el gobierno vietnamita también ha dado prioridad,
desde el principio, a otras áreas más ligadas
a los servicios, como por ejemplo el turismo.
Sin duda, la mejor muestra de todo esto es
Phu Quoc (fu kuok) Island, una isla casi del
tamaño de Singapur que el gobierno quiere
convertir en una meca internacional del turismo
y el ocio.
Y para ello, claro está, ha confiado en el
mercado internacional:
Aquí los turistas no necesitan Visa para
entrar, el gobierno ha construido modernas
infraestructuras y se han dado muchas facilidades
a que los inversores internacionales lleguen
con su dinero.
El resultado es un impresionante boom de hoteles,
resorts, apartamentos, parques temáticos
e incluso un casino.
Los proyectos en marcha se acercan a los 200
y las inversiones ya en marcha superan los
6.000 millones de dólares.
Desde luego, ya os podéis imaginar que las
perspectivas son ahora brillantes para los
habitantes de la isla que hasta ahora sobrevivían
gracias, prácticamente, a una pesca de subsistencia.
Y no solo eso, la llegada de turistas internacionales
es un buen conductor para nuevas ideas que
favorecen el aperturismo y el entendimiento.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, durante los
próximos años Vietnam dará mucho que hablar,
y en Washington lo saben.
OBAMA Y LA APUESTA POR VIETNAM
Ya lo sabéis, es algo sobre lo que insistimos
bastante: Durante sus 8 años en la Casa Blanca,
Barack Obama apostó fuerte por el sudeste
asiático, y hay que decir que Vietnam fue
uno de sus objetivos preferentes.
De hecho, el propio Barack Obama visitó este
país para dar un carpetazo definitivo a las
hostilidades heredadas de la Guerra.
No fue el primer Presidente en hacerlo, tanto
Bill Clinton como George Bush ya lo habían
visitado previamente, pero Obama probablemente
ha sido de los tres el que mejores resultados
logró.
Obama logro la adhesión de Vietnam al TPP,
levantó el embargo a la venta de equipos
militares a este país y nos dejó imágenes
como esta.
En su búsqueda por lograr una estrecha alianza
con Vietnam, algo en lo que por cierto tuvo
éxito, Obama llegó a recibir en la Casa
Blanca al mismísimo Secretario General del
Partido Comunista Chino:
En fin, ¿qué pensáis vosotros?
¿Se convertirá Vietnam en una nueva potencia
asiática?
¿Logrará Donald Trump mantener la estrecha
alianza generada entre este país y Estados
Unidos?
Espero que os haya gustado el vídeo, y ¿aún
no sabes que es este botón?
¡es la nueva versión de VisualPolitik en
inglés!
Así que si quieres repasar la lengua de Shakespeare
no dudes en hacer click y suscribirte.
Y si tienes algún amigo angloparlante, ya
sabes, recomiéndanos.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!